c.s lewis uh begins
his book
the screwtape letters with a quote from
i think it was uh if i remember
correctly saint thomas more
saying that the devil cannot endure to
be mocked and uh and
and that's why he should be because
that's the appropriate response to evil
is to mock it that shouldn't be our only
response to evil but that is an
appropriate response that should be a
big part of our rebuttal as it were to
evil because evil is a proud and it's uh
arrogant haughty self-involved
narcissistic and and it you know props
itself up above everybody but it's
propped up on stilts
which can easily be kicked and knocked
over
which is exactly what we should be doing
and that's why i'm a huge proponent
of mocking
gender ideology which is from the devil
and ironically ricky gervais uh doesn't
believe in the in the devil because he's
an atheist
but he does a great job of mocking him
um including in this there's a there's a
a bit from his new
netflix special which i think was just
um launched on netflix yesterday and
this bit's going viral and of course it
has the left very very angry
and here he is making jokes about gender
ideology now the thing is
you know
dave chappelle gets sort of the credit
as being the brave comedian who will
you know make jokes about the trans
phenomenon and all that kind of stuff
i've always thought that
dave chappelle's jokes are i appreciate
that he's making them at all i guess but
the jokes are i've always thought kind
of pretty pretty safe and tame
um he doesn't go nearly as far as he
could
it always seems to me that dave
chappelle even though he gets credit or
blame depending on how you want to you
know depending on your perspective
uh for being the guy who who will talk
about these kinds of things it always
seems to me like he pulls his
punches and on top of that also uh his
his recent stand-up specials i just
think aren't that funny like he's not
making a lot of jokes he's just sort of
up there
preaching
and but what he's saying in his
preaching isn't really all that
provocative or edgy you know at all um
but here i think
ricky gervais
really goes for it
really goes for it so let's listen to
this
the old-fashioned women oh god you know
the ones with wombs
those dinosaurs
[Music]
no i love the the new whip i know
they're new i mean they're great aren't
they you know the new ones we've been
seeing lately there were the ones with
beards and they're as good as
they're as good as gold i love them
now it's the old fashioned way and now
the old fashioned they go oh they want
to use our toilets why shouldn't they
use your toilets for ladies
they are ladies look at their pronouns
what about this person isn't a lady well
his penis
her penis you [ __ ] figure
what if he rapes me
what if she raped you
you
turned poor
now the great thing is that yeah that's
funny but that is also
exactly what the trans activists
actually say like he didn't say anything
in this uh imaginary conversation
between a sane person and trans activist
he he is fairly representing and this is
this is this shows you how absurd it is
that he could stand on stage as a
stand-up comedian
and simply say exactly what these people
actually say and it's a it's a hilarious
punch line because that's how insane it
is
her penis like that's that's what they
say that is 100
what they say there's absolutely no
straw manning going on there at all
and um is this the right approach like
should should should we be doing this
should should comedians be up there
should anyone be making jokes about this
um
yes
absolutely
because the claims that the gender
ideologues are making and what they're
doing it's it's very serious it's
incredibly damaging
they're hurting people
they're mutilating kids
they're killing people actually putting
kids on a path to despair and suicide so
it's very serious on one hand
but also
their whole world view is totally insane
and ludicrous
and so while we should deal with it on
the serious level as well we should also
highlight just how ludicrous it is
mockery is a very important tool that i
think up until recently
especially when it comes to gender
ideology um
the the sane people have been really
reluctant to use it's a tool that we've
been very reluctant to use
and i say we like not me because i
haven't been like to use it but but
generally speaking you know it's sort of
the universal we we've been very
reluctant to use this
very powerful tool
and it's a tool that the left has um
until recently until they launched their
all-out war like comedy's not allowed
now on the left they don't believe in it
but up until that until they went full
puritan right um
the the tool of mockery is something
they use to great effect
and yes we should be using it here
to again highlight that this is
ludicrous
no we're not going to take it seriously
okay the moment you start talking about
women with penises
this is not
this is not like we're gonna sit down
and have a conversation about it and
take your point of view seriously
okay the moment you talk about men
having babies
we're not going to dignify that by
pretending that there's anything
credible in your claim whatsoever
you're going to be mocked for that
because it's insane
but then
so i wish i could just end it there and
say about ricky gervais great job great
routine uh takes takes it does
legitimately take courage to do what he
did there
and they're gonna come after him i mean
if they went after think again think
about what chappelle said about all this
really mild
okay nothing like that at all and so if
they went after chappelle
uh
they're gonna have to and on top of it
gervais is also a white man
and he's going a lot harder against this
uh than chappelle ever did so they're
gonna come after him it's just gonna be
the hounds of hell after this guy
and so that takes a lot of courage
absolutely
um it shouldn't take courage
this is your job you know you make jokes
you're a comedian
most comedians make jokes about things
that are happening in society this is
the role this is why comedians are
important they're supposed to you know
they're supposed to poke the um
the sacred cows you know
the elephant in the rooms that we don't
talk about in society those are the
things they're supposed to be pointing
at and laughing at that's that's the
role that they are supposed to play is
what makes them important so
um and all that's good and i wish i
could leave it right there
but then in the daily wire article about
this
it says this
quoting ricky gervais in this same
special i guess shortly after that bit
right there he says
okay full disclosure in real life of
course i support trans rights i support
all human rights and trans rights are
human rights
live your best life use your preferred
pronoun well
first of all
that's not gonna save you
ricky like it's
there's nothing there's no qualifier you
can add at the end of that
that's gonna blunt the impact when they
come after you they're going to try to
destroy you now and there's nothing you
could say afterwards
nothing that's going to change that
so you might as well just let the joke
stand the joke which is not really a
joke right just let it stand and move on
to your next material there's no reason
the qualifier oh of course i support
trans rights
but the moment you say that it just it
it
it
has the effect it un
it what's going to undo everything you
just said
because well you support trans rights
well but
they would tell us that it is a matter
of trans rights that biological men
should be able to use the women's room
so do you support that then
or maybe you just mean that uh well i
support human rights and so i support
the human rights of all people including
trans people
well yes if that's what you mean then we
can agree on that because anyone who
believes that human rights exist
believes that they exist in all people
but that's when you say trans rights
that's not what anyone means when they
say that that's not what the trans
people mean
they don't just mean oh i want the same
rights as everybody else
said no that's not what they mean
because if you just wanted the same
rights as everybody else then you
wouldn't need to put the qualifier of it
trans right i want trans rights oh you
just be out there saying i want human
rights
and any trans person marching saying i
want human rights i fully agree you
should have human rights here's the good
news you have them so you're fine like
no one is taking them from you you have
them you're good to go you can put the
sign down go and live your life because
you have human rights you have the same
rights as anybody
so no when they when they march for
trans rights they want more than that
they want they want rights on top of
human rights
okay they want to be able to do things
that other people can't do
prior to trans rights everybody had the
same rules
and had to respect the same rules with
when it comes to bathrooms
you use the bathroom
that is in accordance with your
biological
identity
that's it
doesn't matter how you feel doesn't
matter what's going on in your head
doesn't matter how you identify just
that's it everyone uses the same one
you're coming along and saying no no i
want i want an exception to that i want
to be the exception
and so that's what the trans act of us
are doing
they want to be one exception after
another i want to be exception to this i
want to be the exception to that
i want you to reorient society around me
i want you to toss reality truth
biological science common sense decency
i want you to toss all that out the
window for me
so whether you mean it or not when you
say i support trans rights that is what
you are supporting because that is what
everybody means when they talk about
trans rights
so that's just
man
it's like people come
so close
and it's just this this to me is even
more frustrating than just having
someone who affirms the trans stuff and
like everybody else
it's like when you cut when you you get
right up to the edge
of just being an advocate for the truth
without qualification you get right up
to the edge of it and then you turn back
that's frustrating
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends